Hello, I am Yongwook Choi and I will be presenting on 'Deno: A Next-generation JavaScript runtime'
Currently, I'm working as a developer experience engineer at Riiid
I am making development tools used in companies internally like TVkids or WIK using Deno
This character is the Deno character
Here
Because this Deno character is cute, I have been contributing  the Deno ecosystem
If you have questions or want to contact me
here is my GitHub and Twitter account
so you can follow and I will follow back
First, we'll go over some projects using Node.js and TypeScript
and look at what problems existed
and how Deno was used to solve those problems
Next, I will share improved developer experience using Deno
In fact, I wanted to write that it was an incomparable development experience
That is how big of a merit Deno has compared to Node.js
Today I will talk about Deno
but Node.js has huge ecology
There are many legacies being used in Node.js
so you have be proficient in it as well
So I will talk about
how while using Deno you can still work compatibly with Node.js
Lastly, I will share our team's experience on how we used and adapted to using Deno
Let's consider a situation in which we are making a Node.js project with a TypeScript
First, we will need a package manager to use the diverse library in the JavaScript ecosystem
there is npm, yarn, yarn berry and pnpm as well
We have to choose one package manager
Next, in order to adjust to code quality and style
we have to choose some tools like ESLint or Prettier
And if there are wanted plug-ins, or rules
we have to add those to the setting
Then to increase the coding quality we have to add a testing framework
Jest, Mocha or the recently released ones like Vitest
these testing frameworks are put in the settings for the project
But there is more
Since the TypeScript code can't be used in Node.js right away
there needs to be transpiler settings
Using the TypeScript compiler,  after transforming JavaScript code
and delivered to Node.js
or transpilers like ts-node, sucrase and swc can be used like a TypeScript compiler
or through the register hook when the Node.js is loading the TypeScript module
this can be transferred to a JavaScript transpiler in advance
so that the TypeScript can be used in Node.js
There are many things to be considered for a simple Node.js project
Couldn't there be a much faster and simpler way of starting a project?
It would be great to do modernity coding without all the tasks before
So I want to introduce to you Deno, a new JavaScript runtime that will solve such problems
The problems mentioned before can be solved easily with Deno
First, Deno doesn't use a package manager so there is no need to choose a package manager
third-party modules are imported through URL
and packages are saved in the local cache
Even formatters/linters and tests can be used
without any installation on Deno through subcommands
TypeScript can be used without any special settings
Putting all its strengths aside I want to talk about the improved developer experience of Deno
I want to highlight a few of the big points I feel are important from the perspective of a developer experience
I'll talk one by one
First, Deno has a rich and well-selected standard library that can be used in a variety of situations
Representatively, there are modules like async, bytes, io, streams, http
I'll deal with one at a time
async has many utility functions that can be used with Promise
like debounce, defferred, and delay,
you don't need to use asynchronous functions  in projects
through npm installations or make it by itself
bytes supplies functions that can handle things like Unit8Array
io provides Buffer that can be used for Deno's reader and write interface
Now when you want to read and use
Unit8Array or some data
if you follow with Deno's reader and interface
io library and modules can be of great help
streams provides utility functions and Buffers about web streams API
And http makes http servers easier to use
Also there are functions regarding http errors, status codes and cookies
Node.js has built-in modules that are similar to Deno's default library
These built-in modules have no versionings and is connected to Node.js's runtime
So new versions can't be easily uploaded
For example, when you want to upgrade your Node11
to Node 14 or 16 in a project
In most cases, when we update version, the code is not working
Node.js version can't be easily changed
According to the runtime version the built-in module is fixed
so it will be hard to use new functions
Deno's standard library has versioning separate from runtime
which allows for flexible versioning of the standard library while the runtime version is fixed
Because it is released and imported like other third-party libraries
as you can see by just uploading the library version
you can update easily
Next, Deno provides  Promise based asynchronous API
The many asynchronous APIs provided by Node.js were made before promise
so the main logic still uses the callback method
So to use them in the Promise format promisify function in the util built-module
has to be used
so that the callback method API is transformed into the Promise format
or reprocessed APIs that returns the promise
like fs/promises have to be used
On Deno all asynchronous APIs are Promise based
Therefore the callback style API is not provided at all
Here readFile functions from Node.js and Deno are presented
The Node.js will get callback
get callback and make a second context that is readFile context
and on the last line, the inner binding callback context will be rolled over
which is how the callback is used
On the other hand, Deno on the right,
from the beginning, has readFile function composed of async function
and by using await and calling the inner asynchronous API
it uses Promise based logic
By looking at what I just showed you can tell that Deno's code is much simpler
In Node.js, to change the readFile function in fs
to a Promise format more codes has been added in Node.js
All these codes are for changing into Promise
codes used for changing this readFile to promises in fs promise
So Deno is done with just the function on the right
for returning the API to the promise format
but Node has many codes like this
Also, if there is an unfortunate situation and you have to look into the real code
maybe because there is a bug and you have to look through the inner code
Deno's inner code will be much more convenient to look through
Deno's standard library has a cleaner inner code
As explained earlier, because Deno's standard library
has no big difference between other third part libraries as providing methods,
though it already should be like this, the functions in the standard library in Deno
that would be mostly used will be helpful for debugging or understanding inner actions due to its simplicity
Next, Deno strives to abide by the web platform API
Web platform APIs are those built in web browsers such as Chrome or Firefox
When running functions on runtime outside of web browsers,
the same functions are often already included
In this case, Deno does not recreate the wheel
It implements the Web API that is compatible with the browser
And it is co-compatible with the browser
Like Fetch, Console, Streams, Web Storage, Web Worker
Such Web API is already implemented in Deno
Of course, at Node.js such Web API is partially implemented
But most functions are still experimental, it’s either only partially compatible
Or requires a third-party library
And even if it is implemented, it exists as an internal module
Such internal modules should be called in for the use
At Deno, the API used at browsers can be used right away
So those who usually write browser API code
Can easily write the code that runs at the runtime outside the browser on Deno
Like this below, searching for Web API like localStorage at MDN
Gives us the compatibility table at the bottom and we see Deno
Next, the NPM package we use
It can be a malicious code with various issues
So in this case, at Node.js, this malicious code
Can manipulate the system and the structure cannot respond to it properly
At Deno, when file system, network, environment variable approach is needed
And there is no appropriate  authority, it can stop the run, and avoid this issue
And one of my favorite things
It only supports ES Modules with the module system
At module system, CommonJS, AMD, ES Modules, these are such module systems
And these are, in my opinion, a big barrier into JavaScript for beginners
At Deno, it only supports ESM
So it is possible to write codes regardless of the previous module system
In addition, as I said before, something with so many functions,
The standard library is also written in ESModule, so regardless of the proficiency in JavaScript
It is easy to read the internal code
I have talked about what strengths are there with Deno,
And why it is good compared to Node.js
However good it is,
It’ll be even better to be able to use the broad ecosystem of Node.js, right?
So in this section, I will introduce to you the method
That allows each other’s code to be run in the opposite runtime
There are many ways to run Node.js code at Deno
First, let’s start with how to run the small code fragment
Previously, the small code fragments run at Node.js
Can be replaced with within the Deno standard library
With node compatible modules for compatibility
Not all functions are supported yet
But as seen at the right, most modules are compatible
And the compatibility is dealt with around popular libraries
To increase the compatibility
Not only the small code fragments
The whole code written for Node.js can be run easily as well
Deno has Node compatibility mode
So it allows the use of CommonJS with the diverse global objects
And Node.js API is, as I said,
Not needed to change into the node compatibility module in the Deno’s standard library
It automatically fills polyfill
To use compatibility mode, using deno run compact flag
It can change the overall running condition into compatibility mode
Like this, CommonJS code makes wrapper around it like below
It assesses the whole code internally
The example below has many things omitted
But like the filename at the left, the special variable of CommonJS
Or the process, the overall module, when it runs the right code
This Node CommonJS and its special things are all filled in
Sometimes the big NPM Modules
You may want to import them from Deno code for use
For that case, using a Deno-friendly CDN
You need no other work to use Node.js module
Deno-friendly CDN, for instance, is esm.sh or skypack
When receiving module from this CDN, things done by Node compatibility mode
Is now usable with the automatically processed modules
This CDN automatically changes Common.JS-based codes into ESM
And it provides typing for TypeScript
Replace Various Node.js built-in module to std/node polyfill,
and then inject.
Like you see at the very bottom,
if you import,
You can get the NPM module that is automatically
changed to be usable in Deno.
Previously, I introduced the
method of achieving compatibility with NPM module
by using Node compatibility mode and Deno friendly CDN.
Actually, from the most recent Deno 1.25.2,
Node compatibility mode is removed,
and it was changed to a new method
of importing NPM module, called NPM specifier.
If you use the new NPM specifier, unlike the Node compat mode,
you no longer need to use special flag to change the overall settings,
and you can use NPM module without relying on Deno-friendly CDN.
The method of using is simpler compared to before.
Like Deno friendly CDN had to put address such as esm.sh,
in front of import route,
You only need to put npm:, the NPM prefix.
Like here at the bottom, put Deno run, then the "cowsay",
which is a library where
a strange cow appears and says things.
You can see the NPM module run by Deno run right away.
The compatibility I have talked about so far,
was related to compatibility at the coding level.
In the Node.js ecosystem, there are codes that use API of Node.js,
but Node.js Addon exists, too.
Addons that are written in low level language,
since it uses Node API provided by node to manipulate JavaScript value,
it should provide Node API compatibility.
So that Addon could be used in other runtimes.
The PR for using of Node API compatibility is happening right now,
if this PR is applied, among the many sqlite in NPM,
sqlite using Addon,
or image-processing libraries such as sharp,
could be used on Deno.
So far, it was how to use Node.js code in Deno.
Now, we will look at methods of using
libraries that are written in Deno
used in Node.js.
There is Deno to node transform library called dnt.
If you write a simple transform code using dnt,
Deno code can be easily transformed to Node.js code.
dnt rewrites import identifier of the module,
and injects shim so that many resources in Deno namespace
can be run in Node.js.
The code on the left is the transform code
written by dnt,
If you look from the top,
directory called npm is made,
then build script is written consisting of
the package targeting this directory.
The entry script in this build script
becoming the standard,
Resolve and change the modules one by one to node.js code.
Like you see at the bottom,
you can fill in contents that will be in package.json.
This is not in the example, you can assign a specific npm module
to a specific deno reliability
If you have already written
node code in the original code,
instead of the deno code you're currently using,
you can enable node code.
If there is no reliability on Deno API,
which means Deno standard library
and external library is used,
but those libraries are not directly using Deno API,
dnt does not necessarily need to be used.
Using plugged in called esbuild and esbuild_deno_loader,
Deno code can be easily bundled with esbuild.
Since esbuild has special Deno Wrapper,
bundling code using esbuild on Deno script
can be easily written like
using dnt to write transform code.
The example at the bottom is,
among the Deno standard libraries,
bundling SHA1 code using esbuild.
Lastly, using Node compatibility like this,
I will share an experience where I made development tooling using Deno
that can be run on Node.js ecosystem.
Our team made a development tooling called the Pbkit.
Pbkit is a compilation of development tooling
related to Protocol buffers.
Even though Pbkit requires various runtime
such as Node.js or browser,
we could make Node.js tooling
without losing developer experience using Deno.
All the codes of Pbkit's main repository are written in Deno
There are 3 categories where we have to consider whether it's compatible with Node.js
Pbkit core, pbkit codegen and Protobuf's language server
All of them have different conditions
so the code conversion should be done in different ways
Let me introduce them one by one
Pbkit core is not dependent on NPM
and it was purposefully written in a way that it wouldn't be dependent on Deno
Because the codes must be executed on the browser
but if it's dependent on a particular vendor, then conversion can be a little hard
So this Pbkit which isn't dependent on anything
can be executed on a browser
simply by removing the import request extensions
Of course the conversion from TypeScript to JavaScript is
should be done on the workflow of a client, a developer, or a user
who uses the core codes
And for Codegen, it must be bundled into a file
and in this case, by using esbuild and esbuild_deno_loader,
Deno codes can be bundled without any dependency,  resolution issues
And in this case as well, there's no dependence to Deno API issues, so it's possible
Next, Protocol buffers language server is what we made
and it was made with the npm package that's called  vscode-jsonrpc
but it can only be executed on vscode, which is Node.js
so it was quite hard
For this complex problem, LPS, which is Deno-dependent,
I mean not LPS, but Deno-dependent Protobuf Language Server code,
should be made into a single NPM module using dnt
so vscode plugin changes to npm install pbkit LSP
and it can be installed
And also for projects that must be compatible with Node.js in different settings,
we could use Deno without any issues
So for the last step, can we use it for production?
So when our team was developing the developing tools using Deno,
we did not necessarily need NPM packages, so we could easily introduce Deno
so if you develop a part that's not so dependent on the legacy ecosystem,
then it wouldn't be a problem when introducing Deno to production
If it's reliant on a particular NPM module,
then please check whether it works
when all the modules can be used by using all the methods introduced
And if compatibility issues cannot be solved
if you contribute to this problem, it'd be so much better
but please list it up as the related issues for node compatibility on Deno
and maintainers will help you solve the problem
So there are some things to consider when you use the Node.js ecosystem
but in contrast, it's not so hard to
write codes that work on Node.js on Deno
So we had to write those codes
and just like pkbit, we had to make some strategies like separating dependencies and so on
or using other codes such as dnt or esbuild depending on some situations
So personally, I can use it without any complex settings
but also I don't have to consider other legacy methods in the ecosystem
And I got so much help from the standard library, too, while developing with Deno,
so it was very fun writing JavaScript codes
It doesn't have to be production
You can start with little CLI tooling or blogs
Try writing codes with Deno in any form
and feel how amazing it is
Thank you